This was the best year of my life.
Now, I can understand everything and I can say whatever I need to say.
This is my fourth summer in a work and travel program.
I met so many people here, so many friends.
I like my job.
It's totally worth it.
We help each other.
And I meet a lot of people from different countries.
This is really different.
I like it.
I like this job.
You know that you'll really make a difference, and you'll feel very honored to do this.
When I got here, I was like, "Wow!"
What it does for me is help me know what to do when I get in real life.
My colleagues here are a ton of fun.
Our domestic employees love it...
...'cause they have the opportunity to make friends from all around the world.
And the international students really get an opportunity to immerse themselves...
...and learn about American culture.